Islam sees itself very much as part of
the long judeo-christian biblical
prophetic tradition with which most
Americans certainly are familiar Muslims
accept the Torah and the Hebrew Bible in
its entirety as well as the Gospels and
and the rest of the New Testament as
part of this self revelation of God that
comes from Adam the first man and
according to Islam the first prophet to
Muhammad the seal of the prophets they
see this as one long narrative master
narrative in which the the revelation of
God the self communication of God is
passed down through the prophetic
consciousness of one prophet after
another after another after another and
in fact Islam takes this one step
further and talks about a concept called
the oom al-kitab the mother of books
this notion that exists in the Quran
that all revealed scriptures whether
they be the Hebrew Bible or the New
Testament or whether they be the
Bhagavad Gita or the Upanishads or the
gatha's all revealed scriptures are
essentially derived from a single source
in heaven called the mother of books and
that God's self communication has been
passed down to humanity not in its
entirety but in pieces and as the Quran
says deliberately so for God could have
as the Quran says created one nation one
book and one prophet but he chose
instead to create many nations and many
books and many laws and many prophets so
that the Quran says the nations may know
one another so there is this concept
within Islam that all religions are
inextricably linked to each other
through this passing
John of a prophetic consciousness I I
think to me that's a really beautiful
way of thinking about religion now of
course Muslims believe that that comes
to an end at the Prophet Muhammad but I
think an argument could be made that the
revelation of God did not stop with the
prophets last breath that God is ever
present and and eternal and that the
human societies the human nations that
he made are in a constant state of
evolution they did not come to a stop 14
centuries ago